mais 1987 retenez bien cette date car
c'est à cet instant que le premier tout
premier parc de loisirs de la région
ouvrira ses portes mirapolis à cergy
pontoise
là où les travaux vont actuellement bon
train avec un événement demain la pose
de la tête de gargantua 11 mètres de
haut s'il vous plaît 38 tonnes
le commentaire de jacques allix la tête
a été fait on police tire à une
recouvert de résine polyester avec à
l'intérieur une armature de métal en
gros on peut compter qu'il ya une
trentaine de personnes qui ont travaillé
à cette réalisation
quand cet epci se posera sur ses épaules
la gare gantois sera la plus grande
gueule de miro police avec ses 35 mètres
de haut et son gros ventre creux
visitable en funiculaire niro police la
traction et l'émotion conjuguer en
français avec la mise en scène de nos
grandes légendes le chapiteau central la
réalité avec la danse et le folklore
dans ce futur château des sortilèges le
rêve avec les inventions de léonard de
vinci
ici les légendes bretonnes avec les
chevaliers de la table ronde et les
mystères sous marin de la ville vis au
total 36 attractions manèges aquatiques
pour vous nous l estomac guinguette des
buvettes vous le remplir
pour l'instant un immense chantier qui
tourne discrètement depuis 14 mois
actuellement nous tournons aux environs
de 1 4 à 500 personnes sont ces derniers
temps où les intempéries prompt que
l'effectif est tombé en rond à 100 150
personnes
les animatronics les automates de l'an
2000 entrons dans quelques mois ce
vaisseau de 35 hectares ancré au large
du cergy pontoise
ce sera le premier parc de loisirs de la
région mais attention d'autres bons
sommes tout aussi magique le menace déjà
la concurrence est quelque chose qui va
nous mobiliser pour essayer d'être
meilleur
je ne pense pas que le fait d'aller chez
disney pas passer deux jours empêchera
les gens de venir passer un jour ou deux
chez nous hurle un problème
d'investissement pour les familles quand
vous êtes sur un projet de
l'investissement mais à ce moment là le
parc aura déjà cinq ans il aura grandi
a probablement plus d'hectares qu'il n'a
aujourd'hui plus d'attractions qu'il n'a
aujourd'hui peut-être que disney pourra
pas faire les prix que nous pourrons
faire ici il faudra payer 85 francs un
tri qui on l'espère permettra aux monts
et merveilles du géant gargantua de
différer deux millions et demi de
visiteurs dès la première année
des visiteurs qui devront eux aussi
avoir un solide appétit pour participer
à toutes les attractions en une seule
journée